[Music]
on this Saturday night cases of kovat 19
climb in Canada the virus sweeps the
country we need to focus on clusters so
we can stop those transmission chains
while Quebec declares a health emergency
decreed all elders to stay at home
Canadians abroad told to return home
ASAP as Donald Trump expands his travel
ban to include the UK and Ireland
they've had a little bit of activity
unfortunately the American president
confirms he's finally taken the Cova 19
test I also took the test
Plus freedom at last a Canadian woman
and her Italian travel companion escaped
their captors in Burkina Faso
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with a warning for Canadians
overseas the federal government is
urging travelers to come home now while
commercial flights are still available
u.s. restrictions on flights from
mainland Europe have gone into effect
and will now include the UK and Ireland
many countries in Europe are sealing
their borders and shuttering businesses
and public spaces because of the Cova 19
pandemic we'll have more on that in a
moment
but first the situation here at home
across the country at least 240 people
have tested positive for Kovan 19
Ontario has 26 new cases as of today
there are now more than a hundred
confirmed cases in that province alone
BC has the second highest number of
cases with 73 three new provinces are
reporting cases today Prince Edward
Island confirmed its first case
Newfoundland and Labrador has one case
and Saskatchewan reported its first two
presumptive cases elsewhere New
Brunswick is dealing with two cases
there are four in Manitoba 39 in Alberta
and the number of cases in Quebec has
risen to 24 Quebec provincial government
has adopted a health emergency decree
that will be in place for 10 days
abigail Beeman has the details in our
top story tonight visiting from Boston
the Fernando family explores this
Toronto aquarium one of the few major
attractions open he's getting scary
coming up to the date but we figured
we're gonna do something this weekend
it'd be my birthday whether it's Boston
whether it's somewhere else what's the
difference right now we're staying open
and I said we monitor it hourly we know
exactly how many people are entering the
building exit W so we do control and not
of people in the building so we keep it
lower than what it normally is the new
coronavirus making for a tough start to
March Break but lots of people aren't
staying home we're keeping our distance
we're washing hands we have hand
sanitizer I mean I don't have my
containers of it we've got with us I
mean yeah we have to be alert and
responsible we Friday Ottawa asked
Canadians to avoid travel outside the
country a tweet from the Foreign Affairs
Minister Saturday took things a step
further
commending those already abroad come
back via commercial means while they are
still available all travelers coming to
New Brunswick must at news conferences
Saturday many provinces echoed the
federal message and in some cases took
it further if you travel abroad
you could you you could be subject to
the measures of other countries your one
week trip may become much longer you may
also have reduced access to quality
health care I would like today to ask
all Quebecers over 70 years old so all
elders to stay at on and I would like to
ask all Quebecers that can help them
getting for examples on food to do so
Prince Edward Island declared its first
case of the new coronavirus while the
premier announced he's self isolating
with his family after spending less than
24 hours in the united states nationwide
people have questions and health care
phone lines are overwhelmed in Manitoba
they're hoping some helping hands will
cut down on wait times we've had lots of
interest from physicians nurses students
retired people and we we are very
grateful for that and we will definitely
make use of that Ontario is limiting the
volume of test swabs supplied citing an
increased demand and in BC people with
mild symptoms and returning travelers
who are isolating at home do not need to
be tested unless you get sick enough to
require health care both provinces
stressing it's all about making sure
those who really need the test get it
Abigail Beeman Global News Ottawa in the
u.s. Donald Trump has expanded a travel
ban that now includes the United Kingdom
and Ireland there are nearly 2,500
confirmed cases in America now the
administration is taking measures to
check anyone coming in contact with the
President and vice-president for
symptoms of the respiratory illness
Trump says he has been tested for the
new corona virus the tests came back
negative but as Jennifer Johnson
explains many average Americans are
still waiting for tests to be made
available to them
as the number of Americans infected with
kovat 19 rises a show of force from the
White House task force again attempting
to calm US citizens we're using the full
power of the federal government to
defeat the virus they want to get it
over with quickly and with very little
death the president's ban on travelers
from 26 European countries into the u.s.
went into effect at midnight
now that list will include the UK and
Ireland as of midnight Monday but it's
Americans overseas who are struggling to
get home as airlines reduce flights and
we were hoping that you know the
government would take more concern about
this i airlines would make more of an
effort the bill is passed early Saturday
morning US House lawmakers
overwhelmingly passed a bill providing
free Cova 19 tests for all Americans and
paid emergency leave for workers
sidelined by the pandemic if you are
sick you need not be concerned about
staying home if you're sick stay home
you're not gonna miss a paycheck
officials say millions of test kits are
rapidly being made while more
communities roll out drive-by testing
sites the actual swab is is pretty fast
hospitals are taking extraordinary steps
cedars-sinai Medical Center in Los
Angeles has set up tents to treat
patients in its parking lot doctors
across the u.s. already reporting a
shortage of masks protective clothing
and other critical items what do we do
if we have a limited number of
ventilators the nation's top health
official says they are now mass
producing more masks and other equipment
for hospitals but warning vulnerable
Americans are still at great risk we
will see more cases and we will see more
suffering in death the u.s. is becoming
increasingly paralyzed by the pandemic
normally bustling Penn Station in the
heart of New York City is now a ghost
town millions of students from
kindergarten through college have been
ordered to stay home businesses telling
employees to telework Americans limiting
their exposure as the u.s. braces for a
surge in cases of this deadly virus
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
in the UK the number of deaths doubled
in just 24 hours
Spain is seeing a sharp spike and has
ordered a 15-day national lockdown so
schools restaurants and bars in that
country are closing the World Health
Organization has laid
Europe as the new epicenter of the
corona virus outbreak but as Redman
Shannon reports one of the big headaches
in that part of the world is that dozens
of countries are all tackling the crisis
in different ways at the stroke of noon
Italians show their appreciation for
their health professionals as the
lockdown nation deals with a staggering
death toll Italy so far the worst hit
country in Europe but Spain is following
closely behind appearing to be on a
similar trajectory the country will
observe a 15 day lockdown with only
essential services like pharmacies and
grocery stores to stay open this Spanish
doctor is pleading with young people to
play their part is that he says while
young people may not suffer serious
symptoms they can easily pass on the
virus to the vulnerable Cristina
Rodriguez is in Madrid her parents are a
doctor and nurse she says social media
campaigns like this one are making a
positive difference it's kind of like
stopped the curse from going up and up
and just making it kind of slowed down a
bit because we would we don't want it to
collapse Hospital elsewhere Poland did
not fear among nations that will
completely shut down their borders
and as Donald Trump adds the UK and
Ireland to the u.s. travel ban questions
continue about this strategy being taken
by British leader Boris Johnson based on
advice from government scientists the UK
has not banned public gatherings or
close to schools across face 10 leaders
from Northern Ireland which is part of
the UK and the Republic of Ireland met
on Saturday to try and harmonize their
strategies either side of their open
border there will be differences but the
differences that exist are mostly around
timing there are reports that the UK may
follow its neighbors and
and mass gatherings as early as next
week and now France has followed the
drastic actions of Spain and Italy most
stores restaurants and entertainment
facilities will be closed from midnight
on Saturday as Europe slowly grinds to a
halt Robyn Redman Shannon in London
japan's Prime Minister isn't ready to
declare an emergency Shinzo Abe a says
the 2020 Tokyo Olympics will go on
despite other sporting events being
canceled the death toll in Iran has
jumped and satellite images from space
show newly constructed mass graves
suggesting the true scope of the
outbreak is much worse than that country
is reporting in East Africa the first
kovat 19 cases have been recorded in
Kenya Ethiopia and Sudan and New Zealand
is cracking down on arrivals imposing a
14-day quarantine on anyone flying into
the country as of Sunday Apple is
closing all of its stores outside of
China until March 27th but it's
reopening stores in China where the
pandemic began because new cases there
are in decline in a statement the CEO
says the move is to reduce density and
encourage social distancing in response
to the global spread of Cova 19 tech
support and shopping will still be
available online and staff will continue
to receive their wages the disruption
being caused by kovat 19 is
unprecedented some countries are closing
borders and slowing manufacturing which
will impact global supply chains and
those measures could affect the Canadian
economy
Michael Couture is looking into that for
us tonight Mike guide us through what's
happening well Robin as provinces and
territories try to stop the spread of
the new coronavirus some are limiting
the number of people who can gather at
one time while hockey rinks and museums
are being closed that will undoubtedly
have a heavy impact on the Canadian
economy which is already suffering from
the earlier rail blockades and the drop
in oil prices the federal government is
working on what they're calling a
significant stimulus program to be
presented next week no one thinks the
government will try and spend its way
out of this health care crisis with the
this Council of Canada told us a
long-term plan is needed I would suggest
that the Minister of Finance and others
may want to look at an economic advisory
committee that perhaps is tasked with
the mid to long term what will that
recovery look like because we don't want
to arrive at the other end and say now
what do we do why don't we have people
thinking about that as much as we have
people thinking about the immediate and
the short-term implication a part of
that plan includes the federal budget
which was supposed to be delivered on
March 30th but has now been delayed
because of kovat 19 and some think the
Finance Minister should tear it up and
start from square one I think so I think
clearly this is the primordial economic
issue we were gonna have to deal with
it's gonna be very difficult for the
government to pivot that quickly
obviously you know this is a classic
Black Swan this came out of nowhere
nobody was expecting this the whole
budget planning cycle was going into
other priorities but I think they're
gonna have to pivot the question is will
the government heed that advice and make
a major pivot Robin Mike look at or in
Ottawa thanks Mike we know you have lots
of questions about this virus our Jeff
temple will consult with experts and try
to answer them so email us at your
questions at global news dot CA and our
website has a page dedicated to the new
coronavirus go to global news dot za /
coronavirus coming up how a Canadian
woman held captive in Burkina Faso
managed to escape her kidnappers
there is relief tonight for the family
of a Canadian woman who was abducted in
West Africa more than a year ago
the Canadian government confirms that
Edith Blaye and her Italian companion
Luca che cheto
were located in Mali in December of 2018
the pair was traveling by car in Burkina
Faso heading to Togo to do volunteer
work when they disappeared al-qaeda and
other terror groups are active in that
area of West Africa sources say the pair
fled their captors flagged down a
private vehicle and were dropped off at
a United Nations checkpoint Russian
President Vladimir Putin has signed a
new law that could keep him in power for
16 more years under the current
Constitution Putin's term should expire
in 2024 but the new amendment will allow
him to run for two more terms the
proposed measures sailed through
Russia's Parliament this week with only
one vote against it it must now be
approved by the country's Constitutional
Court and a nationwide referendum next
month Microsoft co-founder Bill Gates is
stepping down from the company's board
Gates says he is leaving the tech giant
to focus on philanthropy
he was Microsoft's CEO until 2000 since
then he has gradually reduced his
involvement in the company Gates is one
of the richest men in the world he
co-founded Microsoft with his childhood
friend Paul Allen in 1975 and his wife
will continue to run the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation still ahead the
daunting new risks for the homeless
during this global pandemic
right across Canada homeless shelters
are on alert for Cova 19 it's a segment
of the population already at high risk
with any serious virus but as we are now
learning the new corona virus can be
devastating as Mike Armstrong explains
shelters and missions are already
cutting services planning for worst-case
scenarios it is a population without
many of the things most take for granted
not just to bed but also things like
sinks and washrooms places to keep clean
put hundreds of homeless people together
in a shelter eating and sleeping close
together and you have the perfect recipe
for a virus like kovat 19 to spread we
are at a heightened risk we can't change
that that's the way a shelter is
shelters are ramping up cleaning
procedures they always worry about germs
even at the best of times that this is
different the homeless population is at
a higher risk from kovat 19 because many
already have other health problems
a lot of them have respiratory tract
illnesses chronic heart disease
hepatitis C much of the last week has
been spent on education and vigilance
making sure people already vulnerable or
careful but the worry now is turning to
what if what would it mean if kovat 19
got into the homeless population most
big cities shelters already hover around
a hundred percent capacity what if
people have to be quarantine if at any
point anyone is asked to self isolate
how are you going to self isolate if you
don't have a home to go to some of the
harder hit areas in the US have already
taken special measures a county in
Washington state bought in Econolodge
motel and has turned it into a
quarantine facility for the homeless
while the city of San Francisco has
least 30 recreational vehicles and
parked them well I think that the the
mayor and and the city has made it very
clear that our number one priority is
vulnerable populations in Montreal the
four major shelters are always in close
contact they've dealt with threats
together before back in 2017 it was an
outbreak of flesh-eating disease they
are now cutting
some services a warming centers closed
as of this weekend some are suspending
volunteer activities they're also only
serving meals to people staying at the
shelters people from off the street can
only get meals to go and many understand
why virtually everybody that we come
into contact with has heard about kovat
19 and is concerned there are worst-case
scenarios being studied shelters and
missions don't have big reserves of cash
or extra facilities they can open up or
one Montreal shelter says it's
considering making an appeal Monday
requesting the military be deployed to
help with the homeless population Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal up next
hidden crime hidden victims supporting
survivors of sex trafficking human
trafficking is a hidden crime in Canada
making it difficult to track the number
of victims recent data from Statistics
Canada shows that 90% of sex trafficking
victims are females between 18 and 24
years of age but the stigma often
prevents them from coming forward
Jamie Dahl shows us how one police
officer is trying to change that not
every sex trade worker is wearing a
miniskirt with fishnet stockings 11
years he has combed these streets often
undercover diving deep into a hidden
world where girls and women are
exploited and sold for sex the
trafficking that we see more often in
the night in Canada is not what you see
in taken it's happening a much more
organic level than what Hollywood would
depict it's nice to see that the police
will
checking on her welfare it's 9:30 in the
morning on a Tuesday the Calgary Vice
units detective Paul Rubin is showing us
one of the city's last remaining strolls
it doesn't take long until we get pulled
over by a patrol officer who suspects
Reuben er is a John I thought that was
you I was gonna send you an email we're
now patrolling this area what's her
story works out here part-time kind of a
hard luck case young girl yeah she
doesn't look very old
yeah she's 20 just let her know if she
wants a clean safe bed to be in for the
next year yeah and let me know when I
can have her there in two hours
okay sounds good I'll let her know
detective rube nur has helped rescue
many young people and adults from the
sex trade across Canada many are being
trafficked but it's a difficult crime to
fight the Internet has made things
exponentially more difficult Airbnb is
thing has made investigations
exponentially more difficult it can be
daunting particularly for the victims
they're gonna have to go to court and
tell their story probably now for the
third or fourth time and this time you
know their alleged abuser will be in the
same room with them the detective works
very closely with reset a year-long
Calgary program for survivors there's a
trafficking survivor that's arriving
from Vancouver and she's going to be
entering the program a reset we pick up
a caseworker and are now headed to the
airport what will she be doing her first
two days a lot of its just
stabilizations just getting meals in
every day getting a good sleep
I have to pack up my whole life and and
put it in three bags and it was so
overwhelming this is Selena not her real
name she's 22 from abbotsford she broke
free from her pimps and is now
determined to leave the sex trade and
her addictions behind I just feel like
I'm a sex object that I'm not valuable
and that was just what I felt was normal
you're driving her to her new home where
she will stay for 30 days with other
survivors before transitioning into
another reset house and continuing her
treatment I'm so ready
I thousand percent ready and there's
nothing that's gonna stop me
I need my worth all in all I'm not gonna
live in the stigma anymore and optimism
encouraging to this detective my
attitude towards sex workers has done a
180 degree change every woman has a
story most of them are heartbreaking if
we can play any part in changing that
narrative then I think we've we've
accomplished something
Jamie doll Global News Calgary and that
is global national for this Saturday I'm
Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
fortune Newfoundland and Labrador thank
you for watching good night
[Music]
you
[Music]